ABCs of AI why is for why I know I know
it doesn't technically start with why
but humor me aside from the more recent
popularity of AI outside of the realm of
Science Fiction why pursue it at all
well AI is a foundational and
transformational Technology it can help
make our everyday life easier and expand
what's possible to make a difference for
Humanity and while right now is a really
exciting time in AI our approach is
founded in our grounding mission to
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful and this includes a responsible
approach to emerging Technologies
including Ai and their various
complexities check out this post to
learn more about our why for AI and be
sure to tune in next week for the last
installment of